it is time for drew's news your fresh
and fluffy good news muffin ooh who
doesn't want a fluffy muffin
with me at the desk is my little banana
nut muffin rossi ross
hi
everybody hi drew
what is your favorite muffin
to be honest my favorite muffin is the
most boring thing about me but i love
like a branny like
yeah yeah almost like a um
someone's mad at me i love it yeah or
like a um carrot cakey kind of oh give
me a carrot cake any day i like a really
nice blueberry where they put that sugar
on top and it's sort of hardened yeah
yeah yeah and you're just like
and then you get to like the base you've
really just annihilated the top
well you know we love the good news pop
culture and interesting findings so
first up we've got news about a friend
and favorite tag teamer to this show
it's miss dakota johnson i love her
she is a regular on this show and her
production company teatime and our
little yellow book collaborate on
created lists for everybody
we love joining forces with her to
co-curate lists of stuff that we love
her and i have selected specifically
that we want to share with you in fact
we just put up our warm and cozy top 10
things to watch you get it on our
website i just put it out on my social
and allure magazine is reporting that
this renaissance woman has revealed that
she has yet another talent oh she just
does uh tattoos oh in her spare time in
her spare time apparently dakota gave
olivia coleman her very first tattoo
using a stick and poke kit oh what is
that now a stick and poke it's like you
dip it in the ink and then you jam it in
the skin
uh
don't get any ideas barrymore that's not
happening
no you know what i would do to you like
the toothpaste on the finger and put
your hand in the hot water like real ca
80s camp movie stuff oh yeah but this
you got a tattoo here on the show you
remember i certainly did get a tattoo
here on the show
right there it says home is where we are
and there's another one under it that
says please god moisturize my skin
um well we don't know what her tattoo is
or where it is um but we do know that it
happened after a wild night celebrating
their new movie the lost daughter
directed by maggie gyllenhaal um and
this movie is getting major major buzz
ross do you have a tattoo yeah i have a
drew's news uh [ __ ] stamp
[Applause]
as well you should
if i just leaned over to grab something
one day and you're like is that the true
smooth logo
[Applause]
um
one person uh that is making headlines
right now and i really wanted to pull
this story particularly for this show is
because
a friend of mine was telling me that her
daughter was really um having a hard
time with social media and
that it was really affecting her mental
wellness and her and i were actually
talking about like
the bella had deeds of the world and how
they're presented with this fabulous
life and you know um and that's what we
see on instagram when we look at their
impossible beauty
um an evolution of someone who goes from
a young girl to this sort of front
running superstars trendsetter
and i went home and i was on instagram
and i found this story and i want to
share it with you
so bella hadid recently posted a very
open and vulnerable post
insider reports that she opened up about
her own mental health and shared photos
of herself at home in some of her
toughest moments
she wrote people forget that everyone is
basically feeling the same way
lost
confused not really sure why they're
here
and she said that we've got to come
together in our flaws and our insecurity
in our joy and our happiness
and accept it all as beautiful and
natural
it resonated it's got you know millions
of likes but let's go beyond the likes
let's just go beyond the bet button
pressing
i'm very grateful to hear this from her
i mean what are your thoughts ross i
think it's never been harder to grow up
you know we all have been there when we
were kids and we were looking at tv or
magazines or just our peers comparing
ourselves to them and trying to hold
ourselves to whatever standard and now
there's just a constant
feed you're being inundated with images
and examples of what you should be and
here is somebody who has a platform that
people are looking at and she's chosen
to be vulnerable and to start a
conversation and the whole point of
social media is to have a conversation
and so it gets a bad rap sometimes
social media is full of bullying or it's
full of cat videos playing with yarn
which i love but
this is
shedding light on how this can be a tool
for good yeah right
i also wonder when we dive so hard and
we binge and indulge and marinate in
this stuff sometimes we have got to pull
ourselves out it's almost human nature
to go you know what i've really had
enough
i actually need to go to another place a
different extreme
and i think that we might be at that
tipping point i'm appreciative of this
moment and i'd like to really
push it forward because i see something
very healthy on the horizon yes i love
this conversation you're having yeah i
feel like in this
this place of real honesty
you feel there i'm inspired by everybody
else let's use this platform for
humanity
and not sensationalism every five
seconds interesting i don't put my kids
out there there's a lot of things i
don't share about myself my life is very
quiet because i'm not sitting there
going i'm putting it all out there but i
know like a little squirrel with my nuts
what to like put in my cheeks and store
for the winter so it's just yours
yes we all should learn our personal
lines and draw the lines for other
people of what we let in what is too
much and what is just that perfect
amount
yeah and only you can decide
we can curate this yeah we can and we
can control this we can control
ourselves we can control our actions we
can control our intake and we can write
a new narrative of what we expect of
social media out there in the world and
leaders who are so you know
famous on these platforms can start to
change the narrative with us as well
which is great absolutely
[Music]
you